hello and welcome to this video when
playing draw hot chick here in a
five-minute pool that boring up another
way we have got if you could have many
in the in the World Championship match
okay my opponent is playing the sideline
here which is are you bloom idly not
brilliant but if I tend to always forget
to look it up and I already should look
it up Castle tips right how does that
work yeah I cannot do these 6 SC 696 is
the problem so probably do this
and this is an occasionally played line
and I tend to always forget to check it
because when it actually happens I'm
sitting around thinking okay you know
why don't I don't I look it up once and
then be okay I mean here I might have a
quality I might but it doesn't feel
particularly great to be honest so what
to do 97 blunders the bishops oh not
this one the queen is extremely annoying
I wonder if I can somehow chase it away
but I don't quite see how this is going
to be possible I mean white also doesn't
have many options you can maybe double
double on the e-file but it doesn't feel
very very attractive either I wonder if
route be a droopy six is actually an
idea on rupee 8b three who them
ultimately doesn't lead to much I don't
like my position yet it's just not it
just not as it is not equal you can
double on the e-file now it doesn't i
was a bit more worried about that
but over its it's annoying okay I'm
ideas to play Queen d7 it's not
attractive at all and I know that I
still I'm still forgetting after that
game to check on check this line I
actually don't expect him to trade but
you can enter the pre move okay yet this
I've failed should be just completely
dead I mean it's a little bit sad i have
to play in that fashion but Chad it is
what it is hmm Jeff it feels difficult
that to do anything here with black I
actually have the slightly worse pawn
structure so Knight f6 net before might
might be coming
hmm it's not it's not the end of the
world maybe he just trades anyway yeah
that's an extremely bad boring game I
always forget to look at this line like
actually can get a fairly comfortable
position here but not in this way this
isn't even all that all that good yes so
anyway to to handle this 96 coming in
really an annoying annoying play maybe
this is nightly 7 i'm taking ages here
also for this you might want to play
five but i don't think this is this is
all that problematic
ah ok boutiques in seven I know it still
doesn't lead to much but he's got more
time and it's still a little bit easier
for him I wonder if he's actually better
you know if it's just equal not quite
sure I don't like to play a 5 on 285
maybe this year first and then c6
pushing back without night before
happening this is actually ok night III
see voice what you can do but this it
doesn't bother me all that much in terms
of equal 0 check yeah I'm fine here
position wise clock is not that good
but I'm catching up at a little bit so
this is good to see jam I had a pretty
bad position out of this opening I mean
maybe it wasn't objectively bad it was
just extremely unattractive to to to
play not sure about d3 if this is a good
idea but okayed it wasn't a good idea
probably but we don't know yet time
morning I'm up here and so I can I kids
to cover this ok we'll get to actually
is an idea here I ass got Kings before I
shoot forgot about that okay whoopsie
too hmm actually funny here it's not so
easy enough for him to make a move what
is he playing a five
don't give much time check fortunately i
would like to figure this out check oh
this is easy oh no it's not easy takes
texting a [ __ ] through King 23 I
overlooked devil that's unfortunate
really hmm and he's stopping me on the
third-ranked what check let's bad oh why
did he allow me to advance all that far
ok maybe his pawns are quicker anyway
guys Poldark Wickham
I can just take f2 how stupid I totally
totally miss plate the sending of course
a little bit also due to the time but
still black resigned actually think i
was getting somewhere like this looks
very awkward for him so i do something
in this ending let's switch on so g5 I
completely overlooked that chat captcha
ok I totally did not see King takes
before it since your battery so good no
I have to do this of course I mean I
should never lose this position sure the
objectively so yeah we probably have a
draw I just overlooked kingly form which
is fairly basic so this is the draw
probably the result that was in this
position all along Yahoo p4 was possible
here maybe I should have thought about
this for bit longer I didn't really take
time there because i was happy to catch
up and play quit moose yeah it's a bit
over yeah it does this this opening line
is an annoyance somehow because it
doesn't get played often and when it
does I always ignore ignore a chat and
forget to check it yeah here this is
probably critical he has an extremely
good setup at the moment witness pieces
and Candice this seems to definitely
lose but probably it is lost it is
probably lost already now that the demo
that dem default line it's it's mostly a
tricky line it's not particularly great
but i tend to attend to
get to check it it's just what it is the
computer gives rupee ATM for before I
guess mmm it's something like that this
is the line where black is fine I simply
never look there look at it and then I
get the same problems like in in every
game yeah here this is not equal and I
think I mean he was mostly content with
playing something quickly I thought like
doubling on the FR would be a bit more
testing I mean yeah i'm slowly an
equalizing the channel check but it took
took time of course yeah this is a bit
more testing but I think I'm reason to
be okay with how I defended this when I
g6 was actually winning now or cool a g5
looked weird anyway with okay I mean if
you're tempted to play quickly when
you're when you are down on time and it
is it is just equal anyway so it didn't
really look for an advantage may be here
I can play tougher I mean rook before
has better for black threaten 85 and
that's a nice one yeah okay that that
each other that leads to the ending
actually the same position i have this
move which I did not really consider
during the game he I mean I did briefly
but I didn't want to invest like again
30 seconds because you need some time to
figure this out I wonder why they are so
here is that a window said a win
you
place this c 50 c for know what said
should be a draw the cabrito gets black
an advantage but this should be a draw
there's no way forward would be reactive
Blackwood winders I think yeah okay that
was them not particularly great thanks
for watching